choisi la liberté j'ai choisi le dollar
mais c'est comme ça qu'ils auraient dû
la peur vous mérite 12 balles dans la
peau sous traite comme un traître
je travaille pour les américains depuis
ce qui s'est passé là-bas et si ça va on
joue à la belote au plan politique je
reviens michel moi j'ai vu à y monter
tout ce que tu as vu pilote écrit mille
faux suicide parce que des crimes n'a
pas ici
quand tu vois bien qu'ils provoquent
joue au les yeux messieurs
qu'est ce que tu vas tomber de haut pour
être dans la ligne tu la vois plus la
ligne
quelqu'un vous coûter mais chocolat si
ça me changeait de camp c'était le côté
là parce qu'on sait plus très bien
j'écoutais la vérité ah ouais quelle
vérité déserteurs espions tu es
communistes il est plus c'est quoi la
vérité moi bien dans les camps on a
caché des juifs c'est aline est en train
d'être des prisonniers politiques
mais c'est de la propagande
1 c'est la propagande une révolution se
répondre un jour combien d'années ça
dure ça fait trente ans michel 30 ans
les gens se font arrêter tous les jours
des fois ya un procès des fois il n'a
pas c'est du facisme arrêt du racisme
c'est ce qu'ils disent là-bas
moustache et on a remplacé un autre
c'est pourquoi son bandeau parents ils
sont morts parce qu'un des types comme
toi obéir aux ordres
les trottoirs genre qu'est ce qui t'a
pris ça à temps tu vas tout [ __ ] en
l'air c'est pas le moment de bouger là
alors tu remontes études rabiboche je
vais vous mais qu'est ce qui te rend fou
c'est lui ou ses ailes
comme aux arcs pas de conneries gens
de quels propos mois